well our starting pitchers for the tampa
bay rays is going to be right-hander
colin mcqueen more of an open for him
here today we already talked about what
he has been able to do in the month of
may he's giving up wonder and run in 10
and a third innings as you take a look
at his season numbers he has been very
very good with the slider the cutter the
occasional
straight fastball
two outs nobody on top of the first
and here's reece hoskins
the 1-2 swung on and lined towards right
there's a base hit
and again a two strike single for reese
hoskins that'll keep the inning alive
for jt romuto
here's jt who returned to the lineup
yesterday after his stay on the injured
list the jt
off the hands blooped out to right
that's going to drop for a base hit
hoskins on his way to third he'll get
there
that ends at 0 for 12 for real muto and
it puts runners on first and third
and two outs for brad miller and we'll
see if kevin cash makes a change here
that's it yep so colin mchugh is done
after two-thirds of an inning
and a little broken bat roller fleming's
going to have to cover he'll take the
toss find the bag and retire the side
it's good for zach
his era 3.84 he's had a good year
his first innings though have been an
issue for him he's allowed 13 first
inning runs and five home runs
so far this season
so one to right one to left two down
here comes g-man choi
go back to back door cutter
look at the miss first strikeout for
ethel and that'll work too
taylor walls is the batter and a strike
three called on the inside corner
beautifully placed sinker
second strikeout brevlin
two outs here's mike zanino
there's a shot wide deep to left
[Applause]
[Music]
12th home run of the year
i already know what we're going to be
doing our stat cast on dwayne
that was a missile
to seamer and cenino by virtue of that
swing he's anticipating it look at him
just go down there and he catches it
with the barrel of the bat and with his
strength an absolute rocket shot wow i
mean that thing got out of here almost
in the blink of an eye metrics on this
home run well it's gonna be
116
0.1 off the bat and the launch angle the
launch angle only at 20 degrees so 3.7
seconds it took to get out andrew napo
dubal herrera and jean segura coming up
against josh fleming two on two outs in
the first
and he takes care of knapp on strikes
right there his first strikeout here's
odubal herrera
herrera is out on strikes back-to-back
strikeouts for fleming's
here's rhys hoskins
3-2
hopper into right here comes phillips
they're now waiting and makes the catch
man left on base
phillips will lead off the bottom of the
third two-nothing race on to the fourth
josh fleming set to go to work against
jt riomudo
that's a cut to miss he's out on strikes
brad miller
that's a foul tip strikeout
now number two
struck out his first time to the plate
he'll be facing zach f1 it'll be choi
meadows and joey wendell
one two pitch
and a strike three paul break down the
middle 93 miles an hour that was a
wendell batting now with a runner at
second and one out ray's already up
two-nothing in the pitch to wendell
and he does andrew knapp hangs on five
strikeouts for effluent phillips 27th
birthday today you just blew a kiss to
the cameraman said i love you
looking right into the camera
high fly ball
deep right miller back happy birthday
brett phillips had just hit one out
phillips third home run of the year and
that will make it three to nothing say
and this pitch gets thrown right into
the swing path look how far across the
plate that is and when you see a catcher
reaching back over the heart what do we
say usually it doesn't end up too good
for the pitcher and it did not
first and third for the ring so the home
run and now back-to-back singles
and joe girardi coming out of that
dugout the raids have the left-handed
bat of choi do up so that's going to be
it
four and two thirds for effluent
that's a shot back toward the corner and
that's going to be off the top
of the wall one road is in
the throw goes into second a double for
joy he scores to rose arena lao advanced
to third
and just like that the rave pack on
another run it's four to nothing
all right well that'll that'll be it for
fleming
so he's done a heck of a job
yeah really was
went away runners on first and third jt
romuto one for two
facing andrew kittredge
that balls hit out towards center field
keermeyer is going back on he'll get
under it tagging from third is herrera
he'll score it's a sac fly for jt romuto
and the phillies are finally on the
board yeah
so here's brad miller with two outs and
a man on miller is oh for two
33 stolen bases this year miller sends
one the opposite way on the run is
meadows he can't get there it's a ground
rule double wow that's stolen yes is
huge
as segura scores it's a 4-2 ball game no
kidding
that brings
joey wendell to the plate
and a live drive out to right field
that'll be in for a base head rounding
third heading for home is a rosarian the
throw is way off line and now here comes
meadows the throw is offline again
two runs score
wendell's caught between second and
third
balm runs him down
and a sloppy 10 seconds comes to a close
with a final out
6-2 game with the bases loaded in the
ninth
two outs
a one-and-two
count on herrera
here is the sixth pitch of the advance
and the fly ball back into center pierre
meyer is going to be there to make the
catch and this game is over the rays
win this with six to two